Wesley yang reported that you met with Tech Titans,
Marc Andreessen and Peter Teal,
both of whom advocate decentralized education.
Can you share anything about this?
Um,
I don't know if I can share anything interesting.
I mean,
I enjoyed the meeting mark and Peter.
I met mark several times.
Um,
I've only met Peter Wants,
although I've spent some time with Eric Weinstein who works with Peter,
you know,
Peter is Libertarian oriented.
Um,
and so
he,
he shares concerns about the potential totalitarian function of Internet
technology and manifesting itself well in,
in the constant monitoring of our behavior and also in,
in the emergent censorship.
Let's say Marc Andreessen,
well Mark's a smart guy and he knows a lot of other smart guys and we,
we spent a lot of time talking about the possibility of online education and,
and uh,
but there isn't anything really exciting I can report about that.
I mean they were all preliminary discussions of a sort to see if we could get
long and if we could talk.
And so far we've been able to,
I am making a fair bit of headway with this university project,
although we don't really conceptualize it as a university project anymore.
We're conceptualizing it as an adaptive learning system and we're trying to use
it to index people's no index knowledge on the web funnel money to creative
producers of educational content,
allow people to test their knowledge no matter how it's generated and to
accredit people properly.
And we'll release,
release more information about that in the upcoming months as we move closer and
closer to a functional prototype.
The plan at the moment,
I've talked to lots of people like Andrea said,
and teal who,
who are very interested in technology and education and who also are very well
capitalized and have had the opportunity multiple times to pull in investors
into this educational project.
But I haven't done that partly because weirdly enough,
you know,
you think money is a solution to a problem,
but it's also,
it's often a problem in and of itself.
And if I generated several million dollars,
let's say,
to fund this educational,
um,
endeavor,
then I would not only have to worry about how to design the educational system,
but then I'd have to worry about how to spend that money and shepherd that money
intelligently.
And that's actually a huge administrative problem of sufficient magnitude to
stop you from doing any creative thinking at all.
So what we're doing instead is I'm funding the university project at the moment
or the online education project as a consequence of my patriot and funding car.
Fixed that in about five seconds this time.
So,
um,
okay.
I'm finding that from my Patriot patrion donations and I like that better.
The only problem is,
is that I would like to offer the people that I have his employees a certain
amount of financial stability.
And so,
and you know,
it isn't obvious to me how stable the Patriot on funding is,
although it's been very stable so far.
But you know,
who knows how that will work out.
So I think what we're going to do is to crowd fund in October or November once
we have a minimal viable product.
And I think I'd rather do that than raise money privately anyways because I
don't want this project to be beholden to anyone.
And I wanted to maintain control over its direction with a small group of
programmers.
You know,
it's often a small group of people who are working tightly together that solve
very complicated problems.
And that's certainly been the case with working.
Say with Daniel Higgins and Robert Peel on the self authoring programs and so
forth.
Small team.
We've,
we've thought about going the venture capital route and expanding and trying to
make a big business out of it.
But our sense was more that,
and maybe we were wrong about this,
but that was better to go directly after customers and to build the business
incrementally and to test it along each step and not to get enticed by the
possibility of Unicorn level money.
And so,
um,
anyways,
that's the,
that's the situation there.
And I've got three really bright people working on this,
um,
open educational platform and it's really quite exciting.
And I would say we're,
we're well ahead of schedule from where I thought we would be.
So that's pretty cool.
Have you spoken to Nassim to lab following your brief Twitter exchange?
We'd love to hear a conversation with the two of you.
I'd like to talk to him too because he's very,
very smart.
He's a,
he's touchy though and so I have some apprehension about that.
I've,
I've talked to lots of touchy people over the last couple of years and I'm a bit
apprehensive about it,
but I would like to do that.
There's a lot of people I'd like to talk to.
He's one of them and you know,
it's,
I'm having a hard time setting up those conversations at the moment because I'm
doing so much touring.
I am talking again to Jonathan Heit though in the near future and I think
probably to Steven pinker as well.
And by the way,
for those of you who are wondering,
um,
I am going to release the,
and so is Sam.
We're going to release the videos from the Sam Harris Peterson debates.
Um,
I'll put them on my youtube channel.
Sam,
we'll put them on his will,
make them into podcasts as well.
I'm going to release the first one on September 1st and uh,
and everyone will have access to it.
Um,
it's taken us a while to figure out exactly how to do this,
partly because Travis Pangbourne who hosted the events wanted to raise some
money with the videos,
at least in part to help offset the costs that he incurred for those events,
which were very expensive,
believe it or not,
and difficult to generate a profit for from on his end.
Um,
and also he wants to translate the material that he already has into multiple
languages.
So we agreed to let him win.
We had to make a three way agreement for this,
you know,
because Sam was involved and I was involved in,
so it was Pangbourne and so,
and we didn't know how the events would go,
you know,
so we weren't actually that concerned with the damn videos to begin with because
we take,
uh,
we,
we'd take an,
uh,
a risk,
I'm not complaining about this by the way,
like I'm not complaining about taking risks,
but we didn't salmon,
I hadn't even met,
you know,
we didn't know if we were going to have conversations that were worthwhile.
We didn't know if anybody would show up for the events.
And so we were way more concerned about whether or not we'd get a crowd of any
sort,
whether the events would be successful and whether we could actually talk then
what we would do with the videos if the,
or even if there would be videos if the events were successful.
And so it turned out that we couldn't talk and we did have useful discussions.
At least we thought so.
And the audiences responded very well and there was large crowds and so it was
successful.
So then it turned out that the videos were worthwhile,
but we hadn't discussed who had control over the videos or who was going to edit
them or any of those things.
And we had to do that post hoc after the fact,
which isn't the best way of doing it.
And then it took Travis a while to assemble a team to do the actual editing.
And so that was our compromise.
And you know,
it would've been better if we could have released the videos and all of that
immediately after the talks.
But you know,
when you're doing something new and you don't know exactly what you're doing,
you're not going to do it perfectly.
And so we didn't do that perfectly,
but the events were good.
And I enjoyed talking to Sam and I learned a lot from the discussion.
I really had to sharpen my thinking.
I really figured out something,
you know,
I figured out that I think the fundamental issue here is how you take the
infinite world of facts that presents itself to you,
independent of the value of those facts.
So value neutral facts and they have to be filtered to a single point,
like a single point of perception because you have to point your eyes at one
thing and your attention at one thing and a single point of action.
And so there's a tremendous reducing of the world of fact to the extraordinarily
simple and targeted rule of Vail or world of value.
And your,
your brain is the instrument that does that reducing and it's sort of,
it's in keeping with Elvis Huxley's suppositions about that and they were
motivated by Henri Bergson the idea that the brain was a reducing valve and that
what psychedelic experience did was open the doors of perception.
Something William Blake also talked about.
The brain seems to be in some sense the part of the structure that reduces the
infinite complexity of the world of facts to the finite and single point domain
of world of values.
And that's partly neurologically instantiated and partly sociologically
instantiated become as we come to a negotiated agreement about what constitutes
value,
just like we do about what constitutes economically.
And so the structure that reduces facts to values is a reducing structure that's
similar caneously and Stan Shealy instantiated neurologically and
sociologically.
And I understand that a lot more clearly because I had these discussions with
Sam and I'm writing a lot about that in this next book,
which is it's a followup.
I s I suspect that's the plan at the moment to 12 rules for life because I had
written originally 40 rules,
so I have more to go.
I've written about half of the new book and I spent a lot of time writing about,
at least in part what I had to become clearer about as a consequence of my
discussions with Harris.
And so I took a look at the videos and I think the debates were productive and,
and their audiences seem to find them.
So,
and certainly salmon.
I did,
I really enjoyed meeting him.
We got along quite well.
He has much better sense of humor than I presumed from listening.
Well,
from the two podcasts we did.
Of course,
I wasn't in great humor when I did those either.
Um,
and you know,
I also think that I'm also,
what would you say I'm a fan of Sam's motivation?
Uh,
or at least as far as I could determine it.
I mean,
he wants to ground the world of value in something that isn't merely arbitrary
revelation.
And Fair enough,
man,
that's a good,
that's a good aim to ground ethics and something that's solid and not just
arbitrary opinion,
but I think that the devil's in the details.
And so that's basically what we discussed.
So,
um.